ja ganz herzlich willkommen zu diesem
seminar zum thema was ist zeit hört mich
jeder gut ich habe in den letzten
semestern häufig festgestellt dass mich
nicht jeder so gut akustisch gehört hat
aber jetzt haben wir ein mikrofon ganz
zu beginn lasse ich die teilnehmerliste
herumgehen bitte tragen sie sich erst
mit dem nachnamen und dann mit dem
vornamen 1 und im zweiten feld bitte
noch ihre e mail adresse unter der sie
regelmäßig zu erreichen sind weil ich
regelmäßige rundmail sie verschicken
werde ich lass dir einfach mal links
durchgehen
und ich lasse auf der anderen seite hier
schon mal den seminar den semester plan
herumgehen keine arbeit gleich sagen
dass er wahrscheinlich nicht ausreichen
wird es in nur 30 stück das ist aber
nicht schlimm
die nachher noch sagen werde haben sie
die möglichkeit alle informationen zu
diesem seminar online direkt zugelegt zu
haben ich zeige ihnen gleich noch wie
das geht also wenn sie jetzt nichts
abbekommen haben halb so schlimm sie
könnte es gleich digital von sich noch
sieben
ok vorab muss ich ein bisschen was
formale sagen also technische aspekte
sie sehen schon ich habe hier ein
aufnahmegerät also jede sitzung wird
akustisch aufgezeichnet dass das darin
da muss ich sie einfach darüber
informieren
also wenn sie sich melden werden sie
aufgezeichnet akustischen nur dass sie
es wissen
das dient dazu dass ich eben die ganzen
sitzung dokumentieren kann und dass sich
im anschluss mir ein bisschen leichter
tun wenn ich zusammenfassung der
jeweiligen sitzung schreibe also jede
sitzung wird von mir im anschluss
möglichst zeitnah dokumentiert
protokolliert und dann ihn auch noch
digital zugänglich gemacht
nur das wissen also es wird alles
akustisch aufgezeichnet ok jetzt ein
weiterer punkt ist ich hatte schon
gesagt wenn sie jetzt nicht eine einen
seminarplan bekommen haben sollten ist
es nicht schlimm weil es gibt ja die app
zum seminar die heißt viel okas und ich
zeige ihnen mal ganz kurz wie die
aussieht
viele der teilnehmer die in anderen
seminaren von mir schon waren kennen die
schon es ist eine app gibt es kostenlos
für android und apple geräte und die
sieht so aus also das ist unser symbol
das ist diese philosophie eule und es
gibt da - darunter wenn sich die app
runterladen und es gibt auch viele
unterpunkte hier laden sie sich doch
ruhig schon mal runter weil wenn sie
jetzt kein seminarplan abbekommen haben
sollten finden sie den und die folien
die ich ihnen gerade zeige auch schon im
menü dieser fiel oka step sie waren sich
die runtergehen in den store geben einen
film cast laden die sich runter und
sehen dann im menü einen neuen menü
eintrag hier dann in diesem menü in dem
slider den sie von links nach rechts
oder wenn sie auf diese drei striche
hier klicken
hier kommen sie ins menü sondern sehen
sie hier einen neuen menü eintrag zum
thema was ist zeit
und unter diesem menü eintrag finden sie
jetzt schon dem seminarplan als ich
finden darin immer den aktuellen sind
nach plan es kann nämlich sein dass wir
für die eine oder andere sitzung mehr
zeit brauchen als wir die eine andere
thematik mehr zeit brauchen und dann
eben für immanuel kant nur nicht nur
zwei sitzungen wie ursprünglich jetzt
geplant benötigen sondern vielleicht 3
wenn sie dann mal ein paar mal
vielleicht nicht da sein konnten sehen
sie dann immer in dem seminarplan den
sich hier aktuell auf der app finden was
wir jetzt an der jeweiligen sitzung
machen und als sie finden da dann auch
die jeweiligen zusammenfassung der
sitzung finden sie auch unter diesem
jeweiligen menüeintrag und sie finden
zum beispiel auch die audioaufzeichnung
zum nachhören können sie direkt von der
app nach sie finden dann auch manchmal
maria videos das habe ich jetzt nicht
vor aber manchmal mache ich
videoaufzeichnungen meine seminare und
sie finden zum beispiel auch gewisse
aber darauf geben jetzt noch genauer
also was hat es damit auf sich
das seminar für die hosentasche wenn sie
in der u bahn stecken und zwar um 11 uhr
50 der u-bahn hierher fahren und dann
denken was haben wir nochmal der letzten
sitzung gemacht was machen wir in der
folgenden holen sich die app und leitern
sie durch sie finden die informationen
sie findet alle seminare
zusammenfassungen wie ich schon sagte
sie finden aktuellen semester plan
sie finden sie mit einer aufzeichnung in
der regel jetzt audioaufzeichnung das
finden quizze die werde ich regelmäßig
machen dann können sie einfach schauen
habe ich verschreibe ich alles
verstanden
können sie den quiz können sie direkt
aus der app starten und sie bekommen
automatische rückmeldung wie viel sie
richtig haben ob sie den quiz bestanden
haben oder nicht der geht natürlich
nicht in die note mit ein aber es ist
für sich selbst denke ich wie gute hilfe
wir wissen einfach ein bisschen zu
testen
[Applaus]
ferner gibt es noch hyper dings wenn sie
mal jetzt auf die abgehen und den
seminarplan sich mal anschauen dann
werden sie sehen dass manche nahmen die
im seminar plan vorkommen wie zb
augustinus dass die blau unterlegt sind
wenn die blau unterlegt sind dann heißt
es dass die hypertext erfasst sind und
in meinem seminar wirklich schon
integriert sind
also sie finden dann zu augustinus
gleich schon so ein paar biografische
daten indem sie einfach auf den hyper
link klicken und werden sie feststellen
von augustinus augustinus wiki artikel
ist plötzlich bezug zur descartes
hergestellt rené descartes und der ist
auch blau unterlegt dann springen sie
von augustinus zu descartes und von
descartes springen sie zu leiden jetzt
und zu wem auch immer
als medial fall ergibt sich hier am ende
dann ein dichtes verwaltungs netz von
links von philosophischen begriffen auch
biografien person begriffen und sie
haben am ende den genauen überblick über
die thematik das ist so mein ziel
ich habe das schon ein paar semester
gemacht ich habe ganz gute erfahrungen
damit sammeln können und möchte das
einfach auch auf dieses seminar anwenden
ein weiterer punkt ist der dass wenn ich
ein ganz nettes feature dass sie immer
dann wenn sich neuigkeiten hier ergeben
im blog oder auf der app dass sie dann
eine push notification von mir bekommt
und ihr smartphone dann kurz ein signal
von sich gibt es vibriert und dann
wissen sie es gibt eine neuigkeit sie
können die natürlich auch ausschalten
hat das können sie in dieser app
ausschauen deaktivieren aber ich finde
das ganze ein ganz nettes feature ja
dann gibt es noch den youtube-kanal viel
okas der heißt genau so können sie mal
drauf gehen auf youtube einfach mal
schauen viel obst und da finden sie dann
jede menge themen sendungen
vielleicht werde ich auch mal also dass
kanal wo ich viele themen sendung drauf
stelle die in einem kleinen studio dreh
bei mir im büro mit meinen hilfskräften
sie finden da aber auch dann interviews
zum beispiel das böse das interessiert
mich sehr das thema des bösen mit einer
psychiaterin die uns erzählt dass das
böse was es damit auf sich hat oder das
böse empfehlen jemand von der
freiwilligen selbstkontrolle die
videofilme oder irgendwelche vorträge
von anderen tagung das finden sie alles
immer auf diesem youtube kanal philo
casting ich möchte auch dieses seminar
an diesen youtube-kanal anbinden so
jetzt haben wir einiges gesagt zum thema
der formalitäten sie bekommen dann auch
wöchentlich von mir und mails in denen
ich auch noch mal alle informationen
zusätzlich schicke sie finden sowieso
alles immer auf der app habe auch dann
im e mail ordner von woche zu woche
und das sieht so aus dass ich ihnen von
woche zu woche immer eine leitfrage
herum schicke mit dem jeweiligen text
den wir lesen wollen also meine seminare
sind immer so verfasst dass sie
historisch systematisch aufgebaut sind
das heißt wir machen wir reden nicht
einfach nur so über zeit was ist jetzt
zeit und so das ist interessant ist
wollen wir natürlich auch machen und wo
sind die ganzen probleme und wo sie wo
gibt's das könnte die perspektiven der
forschung sind wir wollen immer auch
schauen was hat die geschichte der
philosophie zu diesen fragen um den
zeitbegriff zusage also ist es nicht so
dass wir immer das rad neu erfinden
müssen sondern der geschichte der
philosophie wird mir ganz viele
interessante punkte zu diesem thema zeit
und das meine ich mit historisches
thematisch wir lesen klassiker derzeit
philosophie ich habe eine ganze reihe
ausgewählt finden sie auf dem
seminarplan und internet und wir lesen
die nicht einfach nur so sondern wir
lesen die jeweiligen denker ist sind
leider nur männer
vielleicht finde ich auch einen fluss
vielleicht am ende sind noch offen ich
habe da noch einen auf einem slot
vielleicht finden wir noch jemanden
aber bisher sind es nur männer was haben
diese denker dazu gesagt und ist das
überzeugend wie verhalten sie sich
zueinander wo gibt es probleme können
wir das nicht auch anders sehen
das meine ich mit historisches
thematisch also der ausgangspunkt ist
für uns in meinen seminaren immer der
text ein klassischer text also
augustinus aus den bekenntnissen aus dem
konfessionen dieser klassischen
abschnitt über die frage nach der zeit
und diese texte bekommen sie von mir
immer auch digital zugeschnitten sie
können sich die dann ausdrucken oder sie
können die auch am pc lesen alle pdf
dokumente sind durchsuchbare pdf mit ocr
verfahren gibt character recognition
also können mit dem cursor reingehen in
das pdf und sich auch gewisse
textpassagen direkt raus kopieren oder
sie können das pdf durch suchen nach
bestimmten begriffen und sie finden auch
immer diese pdfs mit den jeweiligen
sechsten auf der fibo kastel
sie können sich also direkt auch auf der
app anschauen diese texte so viel zu den
formalitäten mit wegen der hausarbeiten
und prüfungsleistung würde ich sagen
sprich man anderes mal darüber dass
denke es damals noch nicht in der
heutigen sitzung
es ist ja ganz kurz nach seinem bachelor
seminar das heißt eine haus ich sie
können bei mir als reguläre
bachelorstudent hausarbeiten schreiben
referate gehen nicht und die
hausarbeiten sollten zum umfang von
circa zwölf seiten haben
ich werde aber auch noch informationen
zur abfassung und gestaltung von
hausarbeiten in einen eigenen beitrag
auf die lowcost abstellen und auch enorm
herumschicken dann dazu gibt es auch
immer noch das lsf system das kennen sie
da habe ich auch einen eigenen eintrag
unter diesem seminar da finden sie auch
nochmal alles
kommentar sie finden die dreifachen ihre
e mail ordner auf dem sap system ja und
wir machen dann vielleicht in der mitte
des semesters mal so eine fragestunde
darüber wie man solche im hause beiden
schreibt aber so für eine grobe
orientierung also referate gehen nicht
wenn sie lehramt studieren gibt es die
möglichkeit das ist ein protokoll
schreiben dass ein essay da wenden sie
sich an mich einfach per e mail noch mal
aber für diese normalen
bachelorstudenten der ist so dass das
master 12 bis 13 zeiten der hausarbeit
zu einem dieser themen die wir hier im
seminar machen
das ist nun mal vorab gesagt das ist so
der die perspektive und jetzt gehen wir
doch immer mitten ins thema hinein gibt
ein zitat großen fed hier an der wand
käse noch vor was ist also die zeit wenn
mich niemand darüber fragt sich ist wenn
ich es aber jemanden auf seine frage
erklären möchte so weiß ich ist nicht
wer hat das gesagt haben sie eine idee
ich habe es auch in der seminar
ankündigung geschrieben im sap system
einfach mal zu rufen
augustinus genau und er hat gelebt so
354 430 nach christi und ist also ein
spätantike philosoph und die frage ist
überhaupt ein philosophen könnte auch
als theologe bezeichnet werden weil
dieses werk in dem er diese frage nach
der zeit als einer der ersten ist
natürlich schon vor augustinus
interessante überlegung zum thema
derzeit weil er die in einem werk
vorgebracht hat die das sehr
theologisch orientiert ist das sind die
bekenntnisse und wenn sie mal drum herum
lesen über diesen abschnitt den wir in
der nächsten sitzung vielleicht auch
noch eine übernächsten sitzung behandelt
werden dann finden sie häufiger
theologische bezüge
wir können die theorie der zeit sofern
sie überhaupt eine theorie erste die
reflexionen über die zeit bei augustinus
nicht von dem theologischen kontext
lösen
das soll heißen jede theorie derzeit
steht in einem größeren kontext auch ein
physikalischer kontext sei es kann ein
metaphysischer und theologischer kontext
zahlen mit der physik oder biologie die
lehre von die dingen von dem was
existiert das kann aber auch ein app ist
technologischer erkenntnistheoretische
kontext zahlen als die frage was wir
erkennen können
das können ganz verschiedene kontext es
sein innerhalb deren dieses thema zeit
thematisch wird das wollte die nummer so
vorab sagen berücksichtigen sie immer
den kontext die thematik der
thematisierung hintergrund vor dem zeit
fragt wird ist ganz verschieden und das
wollen wir auch immer reflektieren in
diesem seminar jetzt gäbe nochmal zurück
auf dieses zitat hier was ist denn damit
gesagt wenn er jetzt sagt wenn mich
niemand darüber fragt sie 30 es ist aber
jemanden auf seine frage erklären möchte
ist weiß ich es nicht so ein bisschen
paradox wieso weiß es jetzt einmal wenn
ihnen niemand fragt also wieso weiß dass
verzicht und wer weiß es nicht für
jemand anderen oder vielleicht wieder
sprachlichen formulierungen haben city
ich glaube dass da schon was ziemlich
wichtig ist derzeit angesprochen ist
diese problematik derzeit melden sie
sich einfach mal wenn sie nie so kann
man überlegen sonst genau
das wissen die reformen hätten dann
hätte gestern heute irgendwie sowas gut
sie sagen wir haben so ein gefühl genau
wir haben den inneren sinn wird auch
kann sagen das ist was mit einem inneren
sinn zusammen hat thon hat also zeit ist
jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt etwas
was da vor uns liegt wir jetzt so ein
stift denen ich begreifen kann den nicht
mit den augen sehen kann wir können uns
fragen wie können überhaupt die zeit
wahrnehmen was für einen eps
theologischen zugang also
erkenntnistheoretischen zugang können
wir überhaupt zum zurzeit herstellt ist
sei ein objekt liegt zeit als ein
gegenstand vor oder ist zeit nicht
vielmehr der rahmen die
rahmenbedingungen innerhalb deren
überhaupt nur erkannt werden kann ganz
schön gefragt habe ich glaube ich habe
es richtig getroffen also zeit hat auch
immer etwas mit zeit empfindungen zu tun
also er meint dann wohl damit augustiner
so könnte man nicht verstehen wenn mich
niemand darüber fragt sich ist also
dieses wissen ist dann so so so kann ich
es intuitiv gefühlsmäßig empfinden ich
hab' ich spüre es in mir mein zeitgefühl
die zeit verrinnt langsam schneller ich
habe eine zeitliche orientierung ist es
gerade so und soviel uhr ich existiere
in der zeit mit dessen bewusst das ist
es eine dieses subjektivität derzeit
subjektive intuitive vertrautheit mit
der zeit die zeitliche existenz und die
andere frage ist die andere problematik
wenn es jetzt jemand erklären soll
dann bekomme ich große probleme weil
dann muss ich das ganze nämlich im
begriffe packen weil es nicht mehr mit
meiner empfing mit meinem inneren zu tun
hat sondern dann muss ich das ding zeit
als ein objekt definieren wesentliche
eigenschaften analysieren und das ist
was ganz anderes
dann muss ich mich also zurzeit so
verhalten dass die zeit mir
gegenübersteht als ein objekt und die
zeit nicht mehr in mir drin ist also ich
muss mich irgendwie von derzeit
emanzipieren
wenn ich jemand erklären sein muss
vor objektivieren und mir scheint oder
viele philosophen haben
der philosophie geschichte die these
vertreten dass zeit immer so ein
subjektive und auch phänomenalen
charakter hat also zeit ist immer
gefährt gebunden anders subjekte
erkenntnis und nur schwer von diesem
subjekt erkenntnis zu lösen
das würde vielleicht dieser zweite punkt
das zu erklären ein gewisser weise
voraussetzt ich glaube das ist so eine
grundproblem subjektivität und
objektivität seine subjektivität ich
finde es ich weiß es intuitiv und
objektivität ich soll es jemandem
erklären
ja und dann bekommen wir probleme also
zeit hat einen ganz prekären status
einfach zwischen subjektivität
objektivität so viel können wir da schon
raus oder hineinlesen wie auch immer
also augustinus ist ein ganz wichtiger
ausgangspunkt für unser seminar darf ich
zwischenzeitlich der fall werde ich von
ihnen die app schon heruntergeladen hat
gibt schon paradiesisch haben
funktioniert sie auf ihren geräten
ja ok sie sind hier herzlich eingeladen
diese app immer auf ihrem smartphone vor
sich zu haben also das ist das einzige
seminar an der ganzen universität wo sie
verpflichtet sind fast schon sage ich
mal ihr smartphone ständig vor auf dem
tisch zu haben und ständig damit um zu
spielen also sie werden ermutigt dazu im
in diesem diesem ewig im netz in diesem
netzwerk in diesem hypertext im netz des
seminars von begriff zu begriff zu
springen wenn sie nicht mehr wussten wer
augustinus wahl gehen sie schnell die
app schauen sich den artikel an dann
werden sie in hoppla da gibt es einen
verweis zu descartes dann werden sicher
wieder beide karten von descartes kommen
sie darauf
jemand ganz anderes dazu möchte ich sie
einladen und auch anregend animieren das
ist hier in diesem seminar von mir in
meinen seminaren sehr gewünscht also
meine meine maxime ist die digitale
medien im fach philosophie der lehre zu
integrieren systematisch zu fruchtbar zu
machen
ich habe auch ein forschungs ein
lehrprojekt wo ich viel geld bekommen
habe und sie mal die app und alle andere
dinge sind damit finanziert worden also
dieses seminar fährt in diesen rahmen
statt
ok so viel zum formalen und zum einstieg
mit augustinus den man wie gesagt nicht
unterschätzen sagt obwohl das schon sehr
sehr lange nicht mehr unter uns ist aber
das spricht nicht gegen dieses
thematische relevanz ganz im gegenteil
vielleicht zugegangen und jetzt habe ich
ein paar fragen wir notiert die auch
jetzt schon angeklungen sind in der
analyse dieses sehr klassischen zitat
was wir gerade gelesen haben
nebenbei gesagt wenn sie wenn es ihnen
hier zu stickig ist die luft dürfen sie
gerne jederzeit das fenster aufmachen
nehmen sie keine rücksicht auf mich sie
klären das unter sich
frage ist wie existiert zeit das ist
auch eine ganz spannende frage als
erstmal kann sie war existiert sie
überhaupt gibt es überhaupt sein dass
wir auch mal so eine ganz grundsätzliche
frage gibt es überhaupt seit oder ist
zeit nicht nur eine illusion
das ist das gleich zwei mal die erste
frage die ich jetzt gar nicht hier
aufgeschrieben hatten dann wäre wenn es
sie gibt also das ist ja diese bevor
geordnete fragt ob sie es überhaupt gibt
ob sie wirklich nicht nur eine illusion
ist und wenn es sie gibt dann kann man
sich fragen existiert sich auf eine
subjektive weise nur ein bisschen von
der form dass des empfindens gefunden an
einem subjekt der empfindung oder
existiert sich objektiv lässt sich vor
objektivieren und wenn sie sich für
objektivieren lässt dann kann man sich
fragen access sind ist zeit diskret oder
kontinuierlich also diskret bedeutet
gibt es zeit punkte
also nicht mehr weiter die wie dir bahre
einheiten derzeit die moderne physik die
wird das zb behaupten die sagt die zeit
ist gewarnt hält es gibt quanten der
derzeit es gibt zeit funktionen die
nicht mehr weiter analysierbar sind oder
ist zeit kontinuierlich kann ich jede
zeitliche differenz immer weiter bis ins
unendliche dividieren
das ist das ist eine frage die uns
beschäftigen wird und die auch bei
augustinus schon anklingen wird justinus
sagt was ist denn das jetzt augoustinos
geht dann immer auch davon aus es gibt
die zukunft und es gibt die
vergangenheit die vergangenheit die ist
nicht mehr die existiert nicht mehr
die vergangenheit ekstase dimension
könnte man sagen es gibt drei
dimensionen derzeit vergangenheit
gegenwart zukunft und aber sind sagt
existiert jetzt zeit die vergangenheit
der die dimension der zeit existiert
nicht mehr das ist vergangen die zukunft
existiert noch nicht als existiert sie
auch nicht und die gegenwart gut was ist
die gegenwart ist die gegenwart
oktober oder das jahr 2018 oder der
heutige tag bei der heutigen tag die
minute jetzt der augenblick jetzt was
ist das eigentlich das jetzt also das
jetzt ist so minimal sagt den augustinus
dass es immer schon wieder verschwindet
wenn wir uns darauf besinnen
wenn wir es reflektieren ist es schon
wieder weg es ist die dann überhaupt die
zeit also eine ganz spannende frage wie
wir bei augustinus in der nächsten
sitzung sehen werden da hatte ich auch
schon angesprochen den nächsten punkt
wie können wir zeit erkennen wenn wir
diese frage wie sie existiert mal
thematisiert haben wie können wir sie
erkennen
dann brauchen wir einen bestimmten sinn
ein bestimmtes vermögen um sie zu
erkennen wie wir jetzt gegenstände mit
unseren augen mit unseren händen
tastsinn begreifen oder systemische uns
einen zugang verschaffen wie wir können
wir sie erkennen gibt es einen gewissen
sinn ein sinnesorgan für die zeit
die klassische frage ist zeit subjektiv
oder objekte oder gar nur illusionär
das ist eine systemische fragen wir
hängen zeit und freiheit miteinander
zusammen dass es auch ein spannender
punkt da werden wir ganz am ende unserer
sitzung darauf kommen einfach auch die
generelle frage
wir hängen zeit und raum miteinander
zusammen das wird auch noch eine frage
sein raum und zeit sind sie voneinander
abhängig oder sind sie voneinander
unabhängig das wird eine frage sein der
wir bei immanuel kant begegnen werden
und so weiter und so fort
also gibt es ganz viele weitere fragen
die wir stellen können und die sie
vielleicht auch haben haben sie dennoch
eine frage die hier noch gar nicht gibt
es hier auf der folie aufgetaucht ist
sie könnte es gerne die frage noch in
den raum bringen den raum werfen dann
notiere ich sie und dann nehmen wir die
auch noch mit auch vorbei wir sie ja
bitte ein anfang sehr gut genau gibt es
einen absoluten anfang der zeit oder
geht es immer weiter zurück genau diese
absolute anfangen
also gibt es so eine art urknall höher
diese urknall frage und dann diese frage
hat zum beispiel im anerkannte ganz
zentral behandelt in seiner seiner
kritik der reinen vernunft die wir auch
lesen werden gibt es ein anfang oder
kann man sich genauso fragen gibt es ein
ende der zeit dann kann man genauso
fragen sie mal so anfang und ende sind
ganz wichtige punkte bei derzeit sonst
noch irgendwelche fragen die ihnen jetzt
gerade kommen bitte genau also sorgt
vielleicht könnte man auch ein bisschen
noch genereller formieren existiert zeit
überhaupt oder oder wie meinen sie das
jetzt mit
ok
ok also welche konsequenzen ergeben sich
aus der nichtexistenz derzeit so
genau das sind jetzt einige fragen gibt
es auch eine frage haben sie werden
sicherlich auch viele fragen noch stoßen
wir werden die auch alle hier sammeln
und gemeinsam besprechen
also gibt es einen absoluten anfang
derzeit gibt es dann absolut das ende
der zeit und wenn sie eine illusion ist
das müssen noch klären was bedeutet das
für uns als erkennen gewesen das sind
drei sehr wichtige fragen zusammen mit
den fragen die hier bereits an der wand
stehen
sie finden dann wie gesagt alle ja bitte
punktgenau
die frage ist die ob freiheit möglich
ist ohne zeit zum beispiel also ob wir
freiheit nur in der zeit haben können
dass es so eine spannende frage die wir
am ende noch behandelt werden
freiheit ist häufig ein prädikat was wir
endlich ein wesen zu sprechen
also man kann sich natürlich auch jetzt
noch andere wesen vorstellt die nicht
endlich sind und anton friedrich koch
ein ein gegenwärtiger philosoph aus
heidelberg hat ein sehr interessantes
buch geschrieben versuch über wahrheit
und zeit und darin kommt er auf weitere
begriffe zu sprechen im umkreis der zeit
problematik eben wie wahrheit und wie
freiheit
man kann sich jetzt fragen gibt es wesen
die zum beispiel gar nicht der zeit
unterworfen sind ist möglich wenn
offensichtlich sind wir es und welche
konsequenzen hat dieses der zeit
unterworfen sein für andere prädikate
andere qualitäten unserer existenz wie
zum beispiel freiheit wir können uns
natürlich auch noch fragen spielt zeit
für den begriff der wahrheit eine rolle
oder ist der wahrheit' begriff nicht
viel mehr unabhängig von der
zeitlichkeit ich denke dass es erstmal
ein leuchten würde zu sagen wahrheit ist
nicht abhängig von der zeit wahrheit ist
immer etwas über zeitlich ist aber an
der freiheit wird so entspannend es gibt
gute gründe dafür zu sagen freiheit
benötigt zeitlichkeit zeitliche existenz
also ich wollte damit nur sagen einfach
wir hängen zeit und andere begriffe zum
beispiel raum freiheit wahrheit so ganz
große begriffe wie hängen die mit mit
dem begriff zeit zusammen also was
wollen wir jetzt hier eigentlich machen
wir haben verschiedene philosophen und
ich gehe jetzt mal der reihe nach durch
und sagt ein bisschen was zu dem
jeweiligen denker wir beginnen natürlich
mit augustinus das ist ein zitat ich ihn
zum eingang schon hier an die wand
projiziert hatte bei augustinus finden
wir ganz viele sehr fruchtbare gedanken
die den ontologischen status derzeit
betreffen die die zukunft vergangenheit
und gegenwart die sogenannten ekstasen
oder auch dimensionen derzeit wir
treffen und natürlich ist bei augustinus
alles auch in größeren theologischen
kontext verortet als augustiner
sozusagen der gründungsvater diese zeit
problematik wir finden natürlich auch
schon bei aristoteles der focus teams
gelegt hat so ein paar gedanken zum
zeitbegriff und jetzt vielleicht am
rande noch darauf zu sprechen kommen
aber nur am rande
dann wollen wir eine riesen sprung
machen sie sehen wir gehen so ein
bisschen so tendenziell chronologisch
vor
wir wollen dann in die frühe neuzeit bzw
neuzeit gehen zu jack newton wenn dieses
mechanische weltbild und seine zeit
auffassung und wollen die dann
kontrastieren mit albert einstein und
zwar wollen wir hier mit dem satz des
pythagoras das genügt uns gewisse
grundgedanken wir können das nicht alles
natürlich herr leiden aber gibt mit dem
satz des pythagoras können wir gewisse
grund einzig der relativitätstheorie
albert einsteins nachvollziehen das
hängt einfach damit sagen dass die
geschwindigkeit die erreicht werden kann
gedeckelt ist bei 299 kilometer entlang
der 1290 kilometer pro sekunde und das
ist einfach ein limit und das wiederum
bedeutet dass die zeit dass die
geschwindigkeit gedeckelt ist hat
wiederum auswirkungen auf die zeit und
das wollen wir mit dem satz zu tage was
uns mal vorstellen einem
gedankenexperiment in einem raumschiff
es hat sich eine mit einem stein auch
überlegen wir wollen dann schauen
welchen veränderten zeitbegriff kommt
jetzt ein stein in der modernen physik
im vergleich zu der traditionellen musik
die er mechanisch gedacht ist bei newton
wo man davon ausging dass
geschwindigkeit immer weiter steigen da
ist also wir haben hier praktisch an
weiteren punkt noch nämlich zeit und
geschwindigkeit also zeit und andere
physikalische größen wir bekommen über
die geschwindigkeit willkommen natürlich
auch den raum wieder mit ins spiel
also meine geschwindigkeit ist immer
auch eine zurückgelegte strecke pro
zeiteinheit wir bekommen die
räumlichkeiten spieler sowie hängen raum
bei geschwindigkeit und zeit als
physikalische größen länder zusammen wir
wollen diese kurze einzig die über die
grenze der lichtgeschwindigkeit geht uns
hier gemeinsam erarbeiten ich habe dann
sehr guten texte diese grund einsicht
der relativitätstheorie sehr gut
verständlich macht so dass wir das
eigentlich alle hier gemeinsam uns
erarbeiten können nicht her leiden aber
eben versuchen nachzuvollziehen das
wollen wir machen weil sie merken wenn
man von derzeit spricht kommt immer die
relativitätstheorie aber zeit ist doch
relativ wir wollen versuchen
nachzuvollziehen was es mit dieser
relativitätstheorie genau auf sich hat
und wie sich dieser relativistische
zeitbegriff zu den philosophischen zeit
begriffen verhält die wir heben seminar
sonst noch behandeln wollen das will ich
einfach ein bisschen vorwegnehmen sonst
kommt ja immer wieder die seien schon
aber einstand hat doch gesagt dass zeit
und so und so wir wollen versuchen das
ganze hier gemeinsam so weit es geht im
rahmen unserer kenntnisse
nachzuvollziehen
dann betritt wieder in leibnitz ein
realistischer denker der auch etwas dazu
gesagt hat zum zeitbegriff bei leibnitz
ist alles sehr vernünftig alles sehr gut
rational verstehen jetzt versucht die
ganze welt im rahmen einer
mathematischen betrachtung zu verstehen
auch die geometrie ist da ein wichtiger
faktor aber der soll auch nicht so sehr
im zentrum stehen vor allem im zentrum
stehen zudem an
kant dir ganz neue philosophie
entwickelt hat sie haben das bestimmt
schon gehört die sogenannte
transzendentale philosophie wonach eben
die existenz von dingen um die
erkenntnis von dingen immer mit der
beschaffenheit unserer subjektivität in
verbindung steht in engster verbindung
jemandem bekannt hat zb die frage nach
dem anfang nach dem absoluten anfang der
zeit der explizit aufgeworfen seine
kritik der reinen vernunft und hat auch
noch an eine sogenannte transzendentale
theorie des raumes und der zeit
entwickelt ohne raum und zeit gebunden
sind an der subjekte erkenntnis und dass
wir in zwei sitzungen versuchen
nachzuverfolgen daneben uns also genug
zeit wenn es sein muss kann man auch
drei sitzungen nehmen dann ein weiterer
wichtiger philosoph der sogenannten der
des sogenannten deutsche journalismus
friedrich wieder joseph schelling sie
kennen alle die schellingstraße die hier
hundert meter weiter im süden von
unserem raum aus verläuft in richtung
ostvest und shelley hat eine
interessante theorie der geschichte
entwickelt übrigens das ist ein begriff
der jetzt noch gar nicht gefallen ist
nämlich geschichte wie hängt zeit und
geschichte miteinander zusammen
und da haben wir dann auch wieder die
verbindung über freiheit also geschichte
könnte man jetzt mal definieren das
mache jetzt einfach mal so frei heraus
geschichte ist freiheitlich gestaltete
zeit ist als eine besondere form oder
qualität von zeit nämlich zeit unter dem
gesichtspunkt der freiheit
oder würden sie etwas sagen ich war das
kann kann man sagen hat gibt es eine
geschichte vor fünf millionen jahren
was ist das problem wenn ich jetzt sagen
würde vor fünf millionen jahren gab es
eine geschichte und die erzähle ich dir
jetzt mal welches problem hätten sie mit
dieser aussagen
ich kann genauso sagen von fünf
milliarden jahren zuvor vier milliarden
jahren hat sich auf der erde eine
geschichte abgespielt
welches problem hätten sie damit
werden sie da hin wenn man geschichte so
verwendet
ja ich hätte man tun wissenschaftlicher
aber keine überlieferung der geschichte
verstehen was diese dekade tradition so
was das ist ein wichtiger punkt als
geschichte scheint kultur oder tradition
vorauszusetzen
wenn wir jetzt also dinosaurier haben
dinosaurier fraß dinosaurier b
ist das nicht geschichte wir brauchen
eigentlich nicht den gestellt geschichts
begriff zu bemühen der erste
voraussetzung ist wir können einfach
sagen das war nicht biologisch
beschreibbare vorgang der mit den
naturgesetzen oder den biologischen
gesetzen irgendwie dem kontext stand
geschichte scheint ihr es dazu beginnen
wo wir sie richtig daran glaube ich
tradition kultur sprich fire gespielt wo
subjekte sich über ihr eigenes tun
gedanken machen reflektieren auf sich
selbst also selbstbewusstsein es zum
beispiel so ein punkt der ganz wichtig
ist auch mit zeit zusammen hängt also
subjektivität und zeit hang auch ganz
interessant und man scheint ihr es dann
von geschichte von von geschichtlicher
zeitlichkeit sprechen zu können wenn
subjekte sobald subjekte existieren die
man selbstbewusstsein fügen und die über
freiheit verfügen dh die ihr wollen und
handeln selbstbewusst selbstbestimmt
einfließen können sprich die die zeit
gestalten können die also zum beispiel
zukunft planen können sagen was möchte
ich den mal in zehn jahren alles tun die
auch entscheidungen fehlen zum beispiel
sagen ich möchte philosophie studieren
ich möchte nicht irgendwas anderes
studieren sie sehen also da bekommt die
zeit eine ganz andere dimension nämlich
die zeit unter dem exponenten unter dem
aspekt der freiheit und freiheitlich
gestaltete zeit die auch in die zukunft
planen die aber auch in die
vergangenheit zurück wirkt die zb die
vergangene zeit selbst thematisch werden
lässt und zb dokumentiert
geschichtsschreibung betreibt oder für
die zukünftige generation etwas
aufbewahren möchte
also die zeit hinüber retten und die
zeit vor der nicht der vernichtung
bewahren möchte oder manche ereignisse
vor dem vergessen bewahren wollen
erinnerung ist diese sind dann haben wir
das mit freiheit mit mit geschichte zu
tun
stand
hausmeister
die tour
beruf nachgegangen
ich denke ich auch ja also ich denke
also man hier sagen das
selbstbewusstsein des entscheidend ist
dass es mit selbstbewusstsein beginnen
dass also die kultur die keimzelle der
kultur des selbstbewusstseins
dann stellt sich die frage wie hängt
selbstbewusstsein mit freiheit zu sein
ich denke schon dass jemand der selbst
bewusst ist immer auch frei ist also
selbstbewusst jetzt nicht entziehen ich
bin mir meiner selbstbewusst meines wird
das bewusst dass es dann zwar auch in
der folge davon ab einfach dass man sie
auf sich selbst reflektiert das scheint
eine gewisse freiheit vorauszusetzen
nämlich eine freiheit von natürlichen
trieben und natürlichen bedürfnissen
wenn ich immer nur den buchen
naturalistischen darwinistischen
überleben ausgesetzt in diesen
überlebenstrieb im strengsten zähne dann
habe ich nicht so sehr die möglichkeit
über mich selbst zu reflektieren
dann unterliegen diese zwang jetzt mal
ganz sympathisch gesagt an die freiheit
fängt da an wo ich aus diesen
notwendigkeit zusammenhang der natur
heraus drehte von plötzlich meine
gedanken auf mich selbst richtig und
nicht nur auf das bloß überleben also
diese rückkehr des gedankens auf ein
selbst dieses selbstbewusstsein und dann
beginnt kultur dann mache ich mir
gedanken um die zukunft und so weiter
also das scheint schon die keimzelle
zahlen dieses selbstbewusstsein kann
jetzt auch im menschheitsgeschichte ich
bestimmt noch genau datieren wann
selbstbewusstsein zum ersten mal
aufgetreten ist aber ich würde sagen mit
dem auftritt des selbstbewusstseins
beginnt vielleicht wirklich geschichte
und kultur und mit diesen gedanken hat
sich friedrich wilhelm joseph schelling
beschäftigt also geschichte ist nicht
zeit und geschichte
sorry berg so hat ein design
französischer phänomenologie könnte man
sagen der hat dieses zeitempfinden zeit
bewusstsein analysieren also wie fühlt
sich einig zeit an wer diese innere welt
dieses phänomen was geht ein uns vor das
hat natürlich auch an die ganz große
nähe zum ästhetischen wie auch in
frankreich philosophie literatur ist
sehr eng miteinander verwoben sind
also das ist ein sehr interessanter
natürlich auch zeit bewusstsein setzt
natürlich auch subjektivität voraus
phänomenologie sie das stichwort und wo
wir schon bei phänomenologie sind martin
heidegger
ist natürlich auch wird auch der
phänomenologie zu gerechnet auch wenn er
das so nicht nennen würde
das einst philosophie und so weiter und
so fort es viele begriffe dafür
er ist jedenfalls in dieser tradition
der phänomenologie phänomenologie meint
eben die phänomene betrachten sich auf
sich selbst zu besinnen
dieses innere empfinden möglichst genau
zu beschreiben das ist die
phänomenologie also dieses innere
zeitempfinden möglichst klar zu
artikulieren bewusstsein zu bringen und
auch in diesem kontext steht martin
heidegger er hat ein wichtiges werk
geschrieben wissen sie wie das heißt
martin genau das sein und zeit und da
haben wir jetzt wieder eine verbindung
zeit und existenznöte haben wir schon so
ein bisschen existenz dass sein das was
ist und die zeit
und diese frage wie sich existenz
zurzeit für hält die ist ganz ganz
entscheidend für martin heidegger
existenz aber jetzt nicht nur in diesem
dinglichen sinne des science also kann
überhaupt ein gegenstand existieren ohne
dass es die vierte dimension gibt
sondern existenz meint bei martin
heidegger immer die individuelle
existenz letztendlich des menschen sagt
das nicht des jahres geht um seine
existenz philosophische
begrifflichkeiten also welche rolle
spielt zeitlichkeit für unser dasein
sagt halte ja dass wir in der welt
existieren mit unseren ganzen löten
stimmungen und so weiter das ist sehr
wichtig für den bezirk zeit das
wichtigste was unser dasein betrifft und
da werden uns auch ausführlich
beschäftigen heilige hat dann auch die
vergangenheit die gegenwart die zukunft
einen ganz neuen sinne versucht zu
reformieren zu im rahmen seiner existenz
philosophie also ein wichtiger so im
kontext dieser phänomenologie ja und zum
schluss wollen wir mctaggart beim lesen
also fast zum schluss als vorletzten
mctaggart ist ein angelsächsischer
philosoph der eine ganz wichtige
unterscheidung zwischen verschiedenen
reihen der zeit entwickelt hat erkennt
eine sogenannte arai derzeit eine beere
und eine cd und er sagt wir müssen dann
streng unterscheiden zwischen
verschiedenen dimensioniert halten
derzeit nämlich so eine zeit die unseren
zeitempfinden gerecht wird das etwas
vergangen ist gegenwärtig ist und
zukünftig ist von dem jeweiligen
zeitpunkt aus in dem wir uns befinden
und eine zeit er also eine art eine
zeitleiste zu beschreiben ist wo wir
einfach so ein konto früher oder später
als sony sony krise weisen objektivierte
zeit liste ist und zeitstrahl dass das
kann man ebenfalls von diesen
subjektiven zeitempfinden unterscheiden
und das ist nicht sehr wichtige
unterscheidung die mit eckart
vorgenommen hat und die wir auch noch
mal behandeln wollen mit eckart
argumentiert in diesem aufsatz den
gelesen wurden auf
deutsch türke dass die zeit nicht
existiert er vertritt die these dass
zeit eine illusion ist
viele sind der meinung er hat sich darin
gehört aber wir wollen das jedenfalls
auch behandeln und sie könnten zum
beispiel dann wenn man eine hausarbeit
sich mit diesem beispiel werde immer mal
wieder so mögliche themen für
hausarbeiten hier ein streuen sie
könnten zum beispiel sich mit mctaggart
theorie der zeit mal auseinandersetzen
nach hause weil und der frage nachgehen
hatte den recht ist derzeit eine
illusion oder nicht und was sind seine
argumente und überzeugende argumente
also ganz wichtig wird in diesem seminar
sein wie man die jeweiligen argumente zu
betrachten und sie zu prüfen ob sie uns
überzeugen können und dabei kann
natürlich auch hilfreich sein dass wir
die jeweiligen argumente mit bereits
vorhandenen argumenten die wir kennen
gelernt haben in ein verhältnis bringen
und sagen ja aber kann teile doch dieses
argument
und das zieht doch hier mehr das ist
doch hier besser geeignet um dieses
problem zu lösen als jetzt dieses
argument bei mekka das also versuchen
sie gerne auch die jeweiligen theorien
die wir bis dann kennengelernt haben
miteinander in ein gespräch zu bringen
und systematisch genannte abzuwenden und
ganz zum schluss anderen friedrich koch
das ist ein noch leben dafür dass auch
aus heidelberg ich habe ihm auch
studiert der hat eben ein buch
geschrieben versuche wahrheit und zeit
und er versucht den zeitbegriff ganz
innovativ mit verschiedenen anderen
begriffen wie zum beispiel begriff der
freiheit in eine verbindung zu setzen
also das ist jetzt vor erste endpunkt
ich bin aber sehr offen
wenn sie jetzt sagen ich habe da noch
einen ganz ganz tollen philosoph eine
tolle philosophin die da was drüber
geschrieben hat und ich möchte dir gerne
in diesem seminar behandelt
dann dürfen sie mir das gerne jederzeit
sagen schreiben sie eine e-mail
machen sie den vorschlag was wir von
thema dem sollen und dann können wir
gerne dafür auch noch eine sitzung
einrichten so bevor ich zum nächsten
punkt komme wollte ich sie noch fragen
haben sie rückfragen zum programm also
wir sie haben den seminarplan entweder
ausgedruckt oder online ich stelle auch
noch
alle sap system on chip ihm herum
vorsichtigen ist das soweit klar wir
versuchen möglichst uns an diesen
seminarplan zu orientieren und nicht so
viel abweichung ins spiel zu bringen
ich schicke ihnen von woche zu woche
diesen jeweiligen text versucht dann
auch irgendwann mal eine gesamte text
sammlung zu erstellen und schicke ihnen
diesen text zusammen mit gewissen
leitfragen die sich dann immer vor sie
den text lesen sich überlegen als sie
lesen den text nicht einfach so sondern
sie lesen den text immer unter einem
gewissen gesichtspunkt eine gewissen
fragestellung also erschließt sich ihnen
der text viel besser haben sie noch
fragen zum programm oder zu den
philosophen haben sie noch einen
weiteren vorschlag sie können sich da
noch ein bisschen zu hause gedanken
machen jetzt würde ich vorschlagen mache
noch mal kurz die fenster auf ja ist
denn recht ein bisschen
so willst während jetzt frische luft
hier in diese räumlichkeiten sich
ergießt möchte ich sie auf eine angebot
hinweisen auf ein neuen film mein bruder
heißt robert und ist ein idiot kennen
sie diesen film
ich bin darauf aufmerksam gemacht worden
von diesem film produzent und ich will
mal vorlesen was es da geht der neue
film des renommierten deutschen
regisseurs philip gröning mit dem titel
mein bruder heißt robert ist ein idiot
legt seinen schwerpunkt auf die
philosophische ansätze von heilige
augustinus und brentano und der frage
nach der zeit damit präsentierte der
regisseur von diesem film die frau des
polizisten die große stille die am
heißesten diskutierten
wettbewerbsbeitrag der berlinale 2018 so
der ankündigungstext ein kompromissloses
werk über das nächste zeit wird so viel
leben sex und tod eingebettet in die
wirren der pubertät und mit einer
verstörenden wenden seine bilder
zwischen schönheit und grausamkeit
zeigen widersprüche und produzieren
kontroversen so mich hat dieser film
produzent gefragt ein oder sie geben uns
immer über zeit wollen sie nicht ihre
studenten und studentinnen frage und die
lust hätten eine sondervorführung da zu
suchen ich möchte die frage an sie
weitergeben ich werde daran teilnehmen
der termin steht schon fest am freitag
26 oktober von 17 bis zirka 20 uhr da
geht fast drei stunden der film und es
soll auch am ende noch eine diskussion
geben so wünscht das jedenfalls der
filmproduzent und hat mich gefragt ob
ich das machen möchte
wenn jetzt jemand von ihnen interesse
hat und weil mich demnächst den genauen
teilnehmerzahlen mitteilen muss diese
film behandelt eben auch die zeit
problematisch ich selbst habe ich noch
nicht gesehen
ich lasse mich überraschen dann haben
sie die möglichkeit daran teilzunehmen
und sich hier verbindlich in diese liste
einzutreiben die ich jetzt auch noch mal
rum gehen lasse und ich würde nämlich
dann heute bereits dem filmproduzenten
der oberin
organisationen die genaue
teilnehmeranzahl mitteilen dass sie
einfach mal durchgehen
genau da am ende wird noch eine
diskussion stattfinden zu dieser zeit
problematik okay so jetzt haben wir noch
ein bisschen zeit die zeit verfliegt und
das will ich jetzt nicht sagen ich
möchte jetzt auch noch mal an sie kurz
die frage finden
nach den themen die wir hier notiert
haben dass wir noch ein bisschen in der
verbleibenden zeit darüber diskutieren
versuchen wir mal den ausgangspunkt von
martin heidegger zu nehmen der sich
besonders mit dem verhältnis von zeit
und existenz beschäftigt hat also jetzt
nicht so sehr von existenz im sinne der
idee wobei diese frage wirklich
interessant ist alle babys ist mir auch
nicht klar ob wirklich den nehmen wir
jetzt mal räumliche dinge annehmen wir
mal hier zb diesen diesen diese
fernbedienung ob die existieren könnte
ohne zeit das ist ne also ohne die
vierte dimension das sind wirklich
spannende frage normalerweise wenn man
dinge betrachtet das werden sie
sicherlich auch so sehen klammert man
die vierte dimension haus wenn man dinge
beschreibt dann schreibt man sie in den
allermeisten fällen nach dem gewicht
nach ihren räumlichen ausmaß wann wird
denn die zeit bei der betrachtung von
dingen thematisch überlegen sie mal wann
wird die zeit wird sie thematisch unter
dem gesichtspunkt könnte ich dinge auch
unter dem gesichtspunkt der zeit
bestimmt ja genau
oder wenn sie sich ja ferner genau zb
ich stelle jetzt diese fernbedienung auf
ebay reine möchte sie verkaufen
dann müsste ich wäre als halber sagen ob
es ist noch ganz neues also wie alt das
ding jetzt könnte natürlich auch alles
sein und noch nie geöffnet worden seien
aber die zeit hinterlässt ihre spuren an
dinge
das ist oder sie haben sich noch
gemeldet war hier noch eine meldung
sozusagen wieder nicht
bei den ausgaben wird ja sagen bei der
entscheidung die sie jetzt gemeint haben
kommt den ausgeblendet
ok guter punkt also so gingen genese
eines produkts genese und geld nichts
kommt einfach so auf die welt
alles hat seinen hintergrund seine
entstehungskontext an die frage nach dem
ursprung die geschichte dann kommt ja
fast die geschichte rein ich meine
produktionsprozess würde ich nicht als
geschichte sein aber es ist jedenfalls
ein kulturelles phänomen das wir
produktionsmaschine rhin haben die opfer
gegenstände nach einem bestimmten plan
auch hervorbringen also sie sehen die
zeitlichkeit kommt durchaus bei
gegenständen ins spiel und heiliger der
jetzt über sein und zeit redet meint
jetzt nicht so ziert die gegenstände wie
jetzt diese fernbedienung wenn er von
seinen spielt sondern er meint uns also
unsere existenz und heiliger bestimmt
die das verhältnis unserer existenz
zurzeit so dass er sagt wir sind immer
schon in der welt geworfen wenn das
heilige auf verschiedene ekstasen
derzeit ekstasen derzeit sind
verteidiger gewisse dimensionen derzeit
die wenn man ganz abstrakt vergangenheit
gegenwart zukunft nennen könnte und
heiliges hat es diese drei dimensionen
derzeit vergangenheit gegenwart zukunft
die sind eigentlich bezogen auf unsere
existenz als individuen also als
menschen obwohl das hightech nicht
angemessen wir müssen anders von
vergangenheit gegenwart zukunft treten
wenn wir von uns sprechen als wie wenn
wir von losen gegenständen schaffen also
versucht dieser zeitlichen dimensioniert
hat eine ganz neue wendung zu geben
indem er eben ganz stark unterscheide
zwischen großen dingen wie jetzt diese
fernbedienung und uns wir sind zwar auch
irgendwie dinge aber wir sind dinge die
sich auf uns beziehen
und wir legen nicht einfach nur vor wie
es objekt tun und das ist so die grund
als ich von heiliger dass die ganze
existenz unsere existenz zeitlich
getragen ist aber in einem viel tieferen
sinne noch als diese bloße objektiv
beschreibbare objektivierbare zeit und
da kommt natürlich wenn sie wieder in
das programm schauen
ich gehe noch ein bisschen zurück da
kommt anori bergson endspiel
diese subjektive qualität die er sehr
hervorgehoben hat und heiliger versucht
diese große phänomenologische
betrachtung des zeit bewusstseins noch
weiter auszudehnen indem er sie auf
unsere gesamte existenz bezieht
das sind jetzt gewissermaßen dieses
systematischen punkte und ich möchte
jetzt im letzten schritt zu den punkten
die wir hier an die tafel geworfen haben
an die tafel gezeichnet haben noch den
die wenigen philosophen hinzufügen der
dazu was gesagt hat dass sie einfach mal
jetzt eine bestimmte orientierung
bekommen also ein historisches
thematische orientierung bekommen
zeit und bewegung und zeit und raum
haben sie eine idee wäre hier der
jeweilige philosoph ist der sich dazu am
meisten gedanken gemacht hat ja newton
genau und wenn es newton ist dann ist es
natürlich auch noch jemand anderes
einstellen
die frage ist natürlich ob ein stein ein
philosophisch aber was ganz interessant
ist ist ein stern hat sich hat ist auf
diese relativitätstheorie kommen also
erstmal auf die spezielle und dann auf
die allgemeine in dem er sich mit
philosophen auseinandergesetzt hat und
er hatte ein lesekreis einen
philosophischen zirkel und hat da immer
wieder gedankenexperimente angestellt
und das kann man durchaus auch als
philosophische auseinandersetzung an
bezeichnen
sonst noch jemand der ihnen bekannt ist
der zu diesem thema unter die aus der
liste der philosophen etwas gesagt haben
könnte
zeit und raum ja ganz genau
ja
ich denke das sind sehr wichtige
versucht natürlich leibnitz noch könnte
man auch am rande erwähnt aber ich denke
wir haben jetzt mit die wichtigsten
richtung der zeit
die truppe die entropie ist ein
wichtiger man könnte mal kurz erklären
was in taipeh ist
ist das maß der unordnung genau es geht
um ordnung und ich beginne ich habe
beschreibt wurde von rohr zu niedriger
entropie heißt die richtung derzeit
genau ist ein universum die sft lässt
nach und das empfinden wir als zeit
genau was genau das ist hier völlig
richtige richtung es geht um ordnungs
zustellung und in ordnung zuständigen
differenzen letztendlich und die haben
so jedenfalls die einsicht der physik
auf die zeigen auch auf die frage nach
der umkehr barkeit derzeit also kann die
zeit nicht zurück laufen übrigens eine
frage hatten wir noch gar nicht hier
behandelten die eigentlich doch ganz
wichtig ist nämlich gibt es keine
zeitmaschine geben ich finde zb wir
spontan eingefallen ich finde wir
sollten die letzte sitzung die noch heiß
nutzen für gedankenexperimente am
beispiel des derzeit maschinen also hier
geht es dann letztendlich um eine ganz
neue dimension die nicht lohe die nicht
ökologisch ist die nicht apps
theologische sondern die logisch ist es
geht also die frage ob die zeit eine
logik kennt die nicht umkehrbar ist also
ob es logische paradoxien gibt in die
wir geraten wenn wir denken dass wir
derzeit reisen können ich schreibe das
nach hinten also zeitmaschine
das hängt natürlich auch mit der
richtung der zeit zusammen aber ich
denke wir sollten also das ist nicht so
gerade gekommen ist sollten die letzte
sitzung nutzen um uns mit gedanken
experimenten bezüglich zeit reisen
beschäftigen die paradoxien sie kennen
das alle wenn wir in die vergangenheit
reisen und was wir nicht tun sollen aber
so ist eben das getan zum beispiel und
dann irgendeinen verwandten aus dem weg
schaffen
dann würde das eigentlich bedeuten dass
wir das gar nicht tun könnten weil wenn
der nicht existiert dann können wir ja
auch nicht sein also wie können wir den
dann bitte schön aus dem weg schaffen
hatte solche solche paradoxien ergeben
sich da und dann gibt es natürlich die
frage gibt es multi wersen und so ne ich
will jetzt nicht größer ein gedacht
diese fragen wir wollen aber nun mal
diese paradoxien und die logischen
möglichkeiten betrachten
ob es denkbar wäre dass wir zeitreise in
die vergangenheit unternehmen kann wir
wollen einfach nur logisch uns gedanken
machen also was spricht dem was
widerspricht dem was steht dem entgegen
und gibt es nicht doch ein logisches
chronologische möglichkeit dass wir so
was die zeitreisen uns überlegen können
ich finde es ein interessantes thema für
die letzte sitzung soll
gedankenexperimente und paradoxien um
den zeitbegriff herum
richtung der zeit hätte man richtung
derzeit ist zum beispiel auch kant das
kann ich schon mal vorweg nehmen und
auch anton friedrich kocht dieser noch
leben der heidelberger
gerichte zeit derzeit denke ich geht
auch so ein bisschen diese richtung zeit
und kausalität
haben sie eine idee wir dafür ganz
wichtig ist der philosophen die wir
haben
ich sollte vielleicht etwas an weiteren
philosophen zu dieser richtung derzeit
hin zu tun nämlich diesen mctaggart
diesem drittletzten philosophen hier der
diese unterscheidung zwischen
verschiedenen reihen der zeit entwickelt
hat
ja jetzt zum thema zeiten kausalität
kennen sie jemanden kämen dafür in frage
ich kann es auch schon mal verwirklicht
ja
genau bekannt ist ganz wichtig man kann
seine existenz habe jetzt schon so oft
gesagt aber wir können es noch mal sagen
wer hat sich darüber gedanken gemacht
heiliger genommen hatte heiliger genau
wir könnten jetzt auch noch hinschreiben
zeit und geschichte
und das ist wie ich schon sagte
schelling schritte vom joseph schelling
der hat sich als einer der ersten
philosophen wirklich große gedanken
gemacht über die zeit
hier kann ich noch augustinus mit
hinzunehmen ja bitte ja ich denke er hat
hier auch dieses zeit bewusst sein
betont deswegen schreibe ich am besten
zeigen bewusstsein noch und schreibt
dann berg sollen wären sie damit
einverstanden
als man könnte sagen so diese findung
das ist die phänomenologie da also wie
wir zeit empfinden was die kommilitonen
auch am anfang genannt hatte als haben
augustinus fragte er sagte wenn ich es
niemandem sagen soll was zeit ist dann
weiß ich also willst du mich geht dann
weiß ich was zeit ist
damit meinte er wohl wenn ich es recht
zäh dieses zeitempfinden ich bin mit der
zeit unmittelbar vertraut mit meinen
inneren zuständen das erinnere szenen
derzeit nicht ich bin mir meiner
zeitlichen existenz unmittelbar bewusst
aber wenn ich die dann objektivieren
soll nach außen kommunizieren soll dann
bekomme ich probleme
und das ist so und durchaus bergson auch
augustinus kann man jetzt
dass die phänomenologie schreibt es auch
noch hin also diese diese beschreibung
der der inneren zustände
und martin heidegger versucht dann diese
phänomenologische beschreibung nicht
mehr nur auf das einzelne objekt zu
beziehen so letztendlich auf größere
kontexte auf größere team nicht mehr nur
auf das subjektive empfinden wenn
heilige von dasein spricht meint er
nicht
uns als objekt das soll mehr oder
weniger uns in unserer relation zur welt
als ganzes spricht auch von geworfen
haid geht es nicht um einzelne wieder so
und größere strukturen und zusammenhänge
wie immer die wechselwirkung von
individuum und mitwelt umwelt betreffen
genau haben sie sonst noch bemerkung
dazu
oder oder offene fragen haben sie noch
eine frage zum ablauf des seminars
also ich kann jetzt schon sagen hier
bitte diese komponenten wie funktioniert
in die jetztzeit hinten klappt das
machen
okay okay ein guter punkt wollen wir das
auch die letzte sitzung mit aufnehmen
das fand ich spannend also also es geht
doch letztendlich darum also wie zeit
realisiert also durch hirnorganische
prozesse also ich dafür bin ich sehr
offen dass wir uns frage am ende wenn
das wäre durch so eine illusionslose
derzeit hat das also ging in diese
richtung vielleicht das zeit ihm ein pro
ein produkt ist unserer hirnorganische
zuständen könnte man jedenfalls mal die
naturwissenschaft biologischen bin ich
sehr offen dafür ja bitte
ok dann machen wir das einfach so dass
wir wir haben ja als wenn sie mit dem
seminarplan schauen wir haben eine
sitzung für newton und eine verein stein
das ist wieder bei 1 stand auch noch ich
bin wie gesagt ich hatte physik
leistungskurs ab was er gerne gemacht
wie der schule habe ich bin natürlich
keine ausgebildete physiker aber ich
kann etwas aussuchen was uns an
gemeinsamen kenntnisstand sich
erschließen würde was aus der modernen
physik statt
er kann ich ihnen gerne ein paar quellen
neben säuerlich darum gehen dass wir
hier einfach nur informationen auf uns
ein riesen- lassen sind dass wir uns mit
einem text beschäftigten also könnte ich
ihn vielleicht mal ein zwei seiten
herumschicken auf deutsch bestenfalls
vielleicht auf englisch aus einem
neuesten beitrag aus der modernen physik
und dass wir über diesen text dann
diskutieren
jedenfalls sollte albert einstein am
anfang stehen diese relativistischen
zahlen ich kann der gerne auswahl
treffen wir müssen natürlich man
bedenken dass wir das nicht unter
physikalischen gesichtspunkten dann
diskutieren können strecken sind unter
sondern philosophischen aber die physik
wagt sich sehr weit nach vorne wenn es
um die zeit geht bei zeit ja so ein
begriff ist der interessanterweise
sowohl von der west- als auch von der
philosophie als einen grund begriff
angenommen und überschneiden sich
philosophie und physik und da können wir
als philosophen durchaus nämlich auch
betrieben wir müssen immer so ein
bisschen schauen dass wir in der
richtigen disziplin bleiben aber den
zeitbegriff scheint es mit kein problem
zu sein haben sie sonst noch wünsche
oder fragen an anregungen was die
gestaltung des seminars betrifft ist der
zettel dann ist durchgegangen über den
film a ja wunderbar ja so habe ich das
auch genommen ist es interessant um eine
konservative schätzung der potentiellen
interessenten aus dieses seminar
entspricht genau der anzahl derjenigen
die sich da eingetragen hat also circa
zehn das habe ich zum geschätzt das
freut mich diejenigen die sie jetzt
eingetragen haben erhalten von mir dann
demnächst eine e-mail über den genauen
ort die zeit steht schon fest aber den
genauen ort dieser veranstaltung
ansonsten wünsche ihnen jetzt noch einen
guten start in die woche in das die
restlichen der semester und sie hören
dann demnächst von mir wieder über eine
push notification und über eine e mail
was den ablauf der nächsten sitzung
anbelangt bis 6